the reason why you don't normally sink
into the sand when you go to the beach
is due to a physics phenomenon known as
Force chain
basically when a bajillion grains of
sand are jammed together in one place
their weight gets distributed over a
large area keeping you and your camels
safely above ground
but if any water happens to seep up from
underground it will mix with the sand to
create a surface that looks solid what
is it
it's true that real quicksand isn't like
what you see at the movies the reason
why you won't sink right through is
because quicksand is rarely more than a
few feet deep
and even if it was deeper than that
humans are only half as dense as
quicksand so really you couldn't sink
much lower than your waist
that is unless you struggle